servi bien chaude la marmite tour en gel
fait le bonheur des gourmands et
réchauffe les cœurs et les corps un
petit peu de réconfort on prend une
marmiton en gel donc voilà on se régale
un peu de chaleur dans le ventre ça fait
du bien de ce temps là parce qu'on a un
peu froid depuis ce matin à 6h30 à -5
pour installer les chalets on a besoin
de ça bien équilibré pas mal de petits
légumes un peu de riz pour tenir au
corps et chaud donc c'est parfait chou
vert carottes champignons saucisse au
vin de Touraine jambon grillé poulet
mariné Riom cuit au bouillon de volaille
du vin doux local du vermout extra local
de chez Vincent carême la marmite tour
en gel a été pensée à Vernou-sur-Brenne
et l'idée de Romain Chaput le cuisinier
c'est de renouveler la tradition
gastronomique de la Touraine en
réalisant un plat gourmet et gourmand on
démarre avec un deux trois ingrédients
on démarre par les légumes au départ et
puis après on se dit qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait ajouter comme viande donc on la
partie sur down à la base pour aller me
cacher mais pareil qui sont
pas forcément ils mettent tous donc
c'est pour ça qu'on veut vraiment un
plat de partage et que c'était important
de pouvoir trouver des ingrédients les
uns après les autres en fait qui
allaient d'une part bien se marier et
être apprécié du plus grand nombre ça
c'est sûr que c'était vraiment la base à
servir toute l'année le plat s'adapte
aussi aux saisons la marmite tout
rangelle existe aussi en version
estivale les choux sont alors remplacés
par des courgettes